نهر يقع في غرب المغرب يفصل بين ضفتيه
الرباط وسلا وهو الحد بين زقاق المدينه
القديمه والتطور الذي تشهده العاصمه
المغربيه الرباط
نهر ابي الرقراق والذي ترتبط به البنايات
والحكايات
وبالتاكيد الاشخاص هنا محمد الياديني صاحب
الثلاث والخمسين عاما مالك هذا القارب
الصغير والذي ترعرع على تجديفه توارثها من
والده وجده والذين كانوا ولا يزالوا
يعتاشون من خيرات هذا النهار
[موسيقى]
تلك القوارب الخشبيه تعاملك وسيله مواصلات
مهمه للراغبين في تجنب حركه المرور
للذين يعيشون في مكان قريب للبلده القديمه
كما تعد الوسيله الاسهل لوصول الساكنين
بالقرب من النهر لمنازلهم اكثر من سبع
سنين
محمد وجه رساله مهمه بضروره ايلاه اهتمام
اكثر بهذا النهر والذي وصف قاعه بانه مليء
بالكوارث البيئيه والتي اشتكى اصحاب
المنازل المجاوره له من اصول الروائح
الكريهه الى منازلهم محمد السيف العربيه